[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Let's start with
where you're from.
- Kolkata.
- Which part?
- I'm adopted.
I'm not really Indian.
- I'm starting to remember.
- Saroo, our beautiful boy.
- We're very proud of you, son.
- A life I'd forgotten.
[YELLING]
- Are you OK?
- I had another family--
a mother, a brother.
I can still see their faces.
- What happened?
[TRAIN WHISTLE]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[NON-ENGLISH]
- I have to find
my way back home.
- How long were
you on the train?
- A couple of days.
- A couple of days?
[NON-ENGLISH]
- It would take a
lifetime to search
all the stations in India.
[YELLING]
- Do you have any idea what
it's like, how every day
my real brother screams my name?
- Saroo!
[YELLING]
- I always thought that I could
keep this family together.
I need you, Saroo.
- What if you do find home
and they're not even there,
and you just keep searching?
[THUNDER]
- I don't have a choice.
- What was she like?
- Beautiful.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Every night I imagine that
I'm walking those streets home.
And I know every
single step of the way.
And I whisper in
her ear, I'm here.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
CASEY WHITELAW: Hi
everyone and thanks
for joining us here today.
So to celebrate the release
of "Lion," on Google Play--
boy, I've teared up in
there, I have to say.
Even watching the trailer
gets me, even now.
To celebrate the launch
of "Lion" on Google Play,
we have Saroo Brierley
here to do a fireside chat.
So welcome, Saroo.
SAROO BRIERLEY: Thank you.
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
CASEY WHITELAW:
So Saroo's story--
and we're going to hear a lot
more about Saroo's story--
I think is particularly
special for us
here at Google Australia
for a couple of reasons.
Saroo's story is set for
a large part in Tasmania.
So it's a very Australian story.
And also, Google
in Australia, we've
been working on Google
Maps for many years now.
And so seeing the kind
of things that we've
contributed to in the world I
think is really special for us.
I think it's an amazing
representation of what Google's
mission has done in the world.
So you know, Google's
mission is to organize
the world's information and
make it universally accessible.
And through that, these amazing
stories, such as Saroo's story,
become possible through
things like Google Earth.
So we've got Saroo here today.
I've got some questions
here for Saroo and ones
that we have collected from the
Dory that was open yesterday
and earlier today.
And also later on we're
going to open it up
for questions from the floor.
So please, have your questions
ready for Saroo as well.
So welcome, Saroo.
And just to start, we
saw the trailer just now.
But maybe you'd like to
give everybody, especially
those people who
haven't seen the movie,
a bit more of an
explanation of your story.
SAROO BRIERLEY: Yeah,
that was really quick,
but it's a 10-hour story that's
been compressed into two hours.
And now it's probably even more.
But I lived in the
slum suburb of India.
This is 29 years ago.
And I was only about
five years of age
and stood over about
a meter in height.
And one night, I went with
my brother from my hometown
and caught a train to
our local neighboring
station, which was a couple
of hours, just down the road.
And so we got there
about 9, 8 o'clock--
sorry, 8 or 9 o'clock.
And I was quite tired
and weary and sleepy.
I'm only five years of age.
And it's past my bedtime.
And so I grabbed
my brother's hand.
And we stepped off the train
and onto the station platform
and I saw a chair
in front of me.
And so I pulled my
brother towards it.
And my feet are doing the
talking, as they sort of do it
when you're tired.
And I sat down.
And my brother said,
stay here for a minute.
I'll come back to get you.
I went to sleep.
And when I wake up, not
knowing whether I was
sleep for two hours,
three hours, or more--
but when I woke up, my brother
was nowhere to be seen.
And so I thought, he's on
the train that is standing.
Whether it's the
same one that I came
from my hometown or a different
one, I wasn't sure of.
But I made that
impulse decision--
groggy impulse decision-- to
board the train thinking he's
on there.
So I boarded it, went
to sleep in a cubicle,
not knowing that I'm
going on a train that
has a destination unknown.
So I ended up 32 hours, 1,600
kilometers from the safe zone
to a place called Kolkata, where
I survived for months, going
through trials and tribulations
of some of the things of come
across people that said that
they'd help me try and find
my hometown, but they
had an ulterior motive,
and then running
away from there,
and then almost drowning
in the Hooghly River twice,
then to coming across
boy gangs, and then going
to a local prison, to a juvenile
prison, to adoption home.
And then from there being
adopted out to Australia,
Tasmania, where I
always looked after,
loved, shown the Australian way
of life the culture, and so on.
But always had that nostalgia
of being reminiscing of my past
and what an oddity it has
been for such a long time
that I couldn't conceive
how a child could
get from being with his
family to getting on a train
and getting lost.
It just didn't make sense.
Even though it was
saddening, I had
to find the closure of at
least giving a valiant attempt
in trying to find my family,
whichever ways in the means
that I've got at hand.
And so in my latter 20s,
I found Google Earth.
And I had that option of
looking on an atlas of trying
to find Burhanpur, which is
the only name that I remembered
in the way that articulated.
But I had a really
good visual memory.
And I thought, you know, if
there's such an application
that I could use on the
internet that I could match
what's in my memories-- of the
landmarks and the architecture
of my hometown--
to what I can see on cyberspace,
Google Earth, then it
would make the process so
much quicker, as opposed
to going back to India and
trying to find Burhanpur
and a train station that maybe
looks the same, maybe not.
So I went onto Google Earth.
And for years and
years, I searched,
from going haphazardly to
becoming quite methodical
and strategic in the
ways that I thought
about looking for my hometown.
And in 2011, I found that
needle in a haystack.
And in 2012, I found my
hometown, as well as my family
as well.
So that was a quick version.
Even though we could
have 20 coffees and I'd
tell you the 10-hour
version, which
I'm happy to do so, because
I don't mind it myself.
But yeah, it pretty
much happened like that.
But I listened to myself,
my dreams, my gut feelings,
and my memories as well.
And the hope and determination--
I was harnessed with that.
So I think that
those points were
quite integral to
finding what I've been
longing for such a long time.
CASEY WHITELAW: It's
such an amazing story.
Even your compressed
version like this
is just so inspirational.
The movie has been a
huge success worldwide.
What do you think about it?
What do you think there
is about it that's
been so universally acclaimed?
SAROO BRIERLEY: There's so
many attributes to the movie.
And people see it in
so many different ways.
It resonates in people in
I guess political to
scientific to a movement
in the community in
regards to adoption,
from having IVF to having
that option of adopting
as well for couples that
want to have children.
So that is some of the
things, but people just
see it in different ways,
from hope and determination.
And I guess that's mainly the
things that I get talked about,
is adoption.
But other people see it
in other ways, as well.
Do you think nurture or
nature kind of thing,
in regards to when we're
bringing up children.
I guess there's so many things.
Where do you start?
CASEY WHITELAW: I
wasn't joking when
I was saying that
watching the trailer
there was tearing me up.
I have a young son.
And I found the
beginning of that film--
who's seen "Lion"?
I don't know if
anyone could-- yeah.
Oh, fabulous.
That's great.
Look.
SAROO BRIERLEY:
Everyone at Google.
CASEY WHITELAW:
Watching those scenes
where you're lost on
the train and then
surviving in Kolkata
were just heartbreaking.
With my own young
son in particular,
I just couldn't
think of anything
that was more directly
tugging on my heartstrings
than seeing somebody
go through that.
So I think that is really
something very universal,
even on that quest also to
try and find your family.
SAROO BRIERLEY: Yeah.
I guess that particular scene--
you've got to be a fighter.
And to survive, you've got to
fight, day by day, to live.
And it shocks people when they
see a scene like, I guess.
And it's, we live in
such a lucky world--
and a country as well--
that we're not open to what
I went through and seeing
that kind of scenery.
So it affects people
to depths where
they've never really gone to.
And I guess probably the
whole film does that, really.
But more particularly,
specifically that scene
in Kolkata, which could have
been lengthened as well,
but you saw a glimpse of
what it's actually like.
CASEY WHITELAW: Thank
you for not making
it even more [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
So one part of the film in
particular I wanted to dig into
was the search, so
from when you started
thinking that you really
wanted to find your hometown
and using technology to do so.
I'd love to know more
about your process.
We saw some of this in the film.
And I don't know how accurately
that's representing it.
We had maps and these
search radii and so forth.
Can you tell us what was
your mindset going in?
And then what did you do?
How did that search work?
SAROO BRIERLEY: Well initially,
I thought, you've got YouTube
and you've got access
to information,
as opposed to going
to the library.
And if you wanted
to play the guitar,
why pay a tuition when
you can go onto YouTube
and learn yourself?
And so it started from there.
And I thought, you know,
the internet has got so much
information-- and one
of it's Google Earth--
that I could use this
application, as opposed
to going to India
and paying thousands
and thousands of dollars and
maybe getting nowhere, ever.
And so when Google Earth
came about, I thought--
not knowing what I'm really
getting into, because once I
started using it, I became
quite obsessed and regimented--
finishing work,
coming home at 5:30,
putting the laptop, which
my girlfriend at the time
called it a fat top,
because I sat on the couch
and there it was.
Dinner wasn't cooked.
Nothing.
So until midnight and
early hours of the mornings
as well till 5 o'clock,
6 o'clock in the morning,
and then forget to go to work,
even though it was my family
business, and arrive late--
5:00 to 5:00, which 5
o'clock was finishing time.
And so you became
quite obsessed and not
realizing that you're
shutting the world away
and concentrating in trying to
find something that you've been
longing for such a long time.
And so from being haphazardly
looking to becoming methodical,
it's like well, you've got to
take things a step at a time.
You've got to use what you know,
and not what you don't know.
And so I knew that the
trains went at around 70,
60 kilometers an hour, roughly.
And then I had a
rough guesstimate
that I was on the train for
about 12 hours, but knowing now
it was 32 hours.
So I didn't really
have a lot to go on.
But at least I had
something to start,
which is better than nothing.
And so that's the way the
radius line sort of came about.
It's like you know point B,
but you don't know point A.
And I ended up in
Kolkata, as we all know.
And so perhaps this
radius line can
help in creating a
search conference.
And so I put a line
out from Kolkata,
right down from north to south.
And that created
that hemisphere.
And I knew that
the hometown's not
going to be straight on
the radius line there,
but it's going to be
in and out, roughly.
So that gave a
bit of a guidance.
And so you segregated
the north of India,
segregated the south of India.
And you were left with
this rectangular piece
of after years and years of
searching, and pushing things
apart, that this is
all you're left with.
And that radius line
was almost telling you
that this is where
you should be looking
after segregating those two
points, north and south.
And calling it providence
or serendipity, I ended up--
not that I ever conceived that
I could possibly believe--
you could have ended up from the
west side of India to the east.
But let's not have
any stones unturned
and take a shot at looking
at the west side of India.
Hence, I did.
And I found that needle in a
haystack, which a lot of people
thought I couldn't, in
2011, at around 2 o'clock
in the morning.
So back when I was a
teenager, I thought to myself,
in the latter teens, that
atlas is no good for me.
But I hope one day that
there would be a program--
not knowing that it's embryonic
at that point of time.
And then, in 2005-2006, it
was there, the application
of Google Earth.
Even though I thought
about it back then,
it became apparent in reality
in 2006, when I used it.
And so Google Earth is the
catalyst of finding my family.
And I'm sure there are
other people out there
in the world too that
have used the program
to find what they've longing
for such a long time.
CASEY WHITELAW:
For most of us, I
think it's usually our rooftop.
You know, we take it for
granted when we start out.
The first thing that everybody
does-- and it turns out this
is universal, and the
first thing everybody does.
We thought that
what they'd do is
go visit the Grand Canyon
or the Eiffel Tower
or something like that.
But in truth, everybody
types in their home address.
SAROO BRIERLEY: Yeah,
see if it's there.
CASEY WHITELAW: Goes to
look at it-- yep, yep,
that is indeed my house.
[LAUGHTER]
The same way.
And in some ways,
that was actually
exactly what you were doing.
SAROO BRIERLEY:
Well I did, yeah.
It was exactly the
thing that I did.
I actually saw my mum
watering the garden.
But you guys took her photo.
CASEY WHITELAW:
In Tasi, you mean?
SAROO BRIERLEY: Yeah.
CASEY WHITELAW: Yeah.
SAROO BRIERLEY: Did you
know that it was there,
watering the garden?
CASEY WHITELAW: But
you had somewhere else
to find that was a
lot harder for you
to find than that, as well.
SAROO BRIERLEY: Yeah, but
it was a starting point.
And it wasn't as easy as
just getting on Google Earth
and doing what I did.
You had to arm yourself
with information.
And mum and dad were a
major part of my life.
They fortified with their
knowledge within me,
really, of my
understanding and so on.
But there was other
parts to myself too,
to having that sort of a
nurturing and push in wanting
to also keep going, as well.
Because a lot of
people can become--
this is just a waste of time.
It's so futile.
And let's give up.
CASEY WHITELAW: You said
it was five years from when
you started using Earth
to try and find it,
until 2011, when you did?
SAROO BRIERLEY: Yes.
CASEY WHITELAW: How do
you keep going five years?
SAROO BRIERLEY: I don't tell
a lot of people about it.
There's two things to it.
The first was
astral projections.
And a lot of people would
find it really hard,
and years and
years, to ever come
to that point of
astral projection.
And astral projection
is where you have
that out-of-body experience.
And I had astral projections
when I came to Australia--
always had the out-of-body
experience of going to sleep.
Hence why I wake up in the
morning abed with a sore head,
because I never really slept.
I had this thing in my
subconscious going on.
And going into astral projection
of going out of the body,
into space, and
then materializing
at the door of my house,
where I was born, and going in
and hovering over my family
to tell them that I'm OK,
and one day I'll see you.
So you know there was that, in
the recurring dreams and so on.
I didn't really
know what it meant.
I really didn't tell people.
I didn't tell my
parents, until later on.
But the other
integral part, too,
which I don't really
tell many people
about as well, because
I just don't know
how they'd understand it much--
but having people that
are ancient philosophers
and mathematicians, like
Isaac Newton and Nikola Tesla
and Pythagoras and
all these people--
these people have left
a legacy on this Earth.
And I've always
looked towards them,
as in you guys have autonomously
transcended in finding things,
as well as Martin Luther King.
These are great people.
And I thought, I hope I could
be like you guys one day, too,
of trying to fulfill something
that I've been wanting
for such a long time.
And I read about
them, and so on.
And they're a real
inspiration to me.
Because when you have Kanye
West and Nikola Tesla--
everyone knows who's Kanye
West, but no one would really
know who this other person is.
CASEY WHITELAW: Tesla was
actually a pretty good rapper.
SAROO BRIERLEY: Oh, was he?
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, no, really?
But yeah, he was a
great philosopher too.
But yeah, these people
were quite integral part
of my life too, that
they helped in making
me want to keep going.
Because they didn't stop.
They kept on going.
And not having much help
from other people, too--
they autonomously tried.
CASEY WHITELAW: And so for
you was it autonomous as well?
Hearing about this amazing
internal drive that you had,
did anybody else help
you through this?
Did you get friends to
look on Earth as well?
Was it just you?
SAROO BRIERLEY: No,
it was all by myself.
I didn't want to tell
many people about it.
Because I thought by telling
people, even to my parents,
they would slow me down.
And I would go through the
phasing stage and the steps
that I need to go,
even though sometimes I
may be veering away, but
it's all a learning curve.
If I make a mistake--
well, I've learned something.
Then I can realign myself
and go in the directions
that I need to.
So I thought that by telling
people, that would slow me down
by Saroo, look, that's the past.
This is now.
And that's the future.
Forget about the past.
You're in a lucky place
with a great family.
I think your past is
really putting you down
into progressing in your life.
And if I had listened to them,
even though they were just
trying to look after
me as friends would,
maybe I won't be here and this
story would never come about.
But I didn't want to listen.
I wanted to do
something that I wanted
to do, think outside the
square that you're living
and listen to your mind
and your gut feelings
and what they're telling you.
So yeah, it's one
of those things
that you've got to
do yourself and not
other people have
your influence.
But it was a personal journey.
A story like this, of my past,
you just don't tell to anyone.
It's private.
And I'm sure we all
have private stories
that we don't want to tell
your best friend or your mum.
And this was my
private story, that I
wanted to do things
myself, and I
didn't want to shoot
too far ahead of myself.
It's like, hey, I'm
using Google Earth.
People would come up and
say, why don't you do this?
Why don't you do that?
And it becomes very cluttered.
And you've got to defragment--
you're trying to defragment
itself, let alone have
other people's problems
coming in and influences.
I achieve better by
myself, acquiring knowledge
from other people, but
not have other people
invest themselves helping.
CASEY WHITELAW: So you
were just five when you
left your home on the train.
What were the memories
that you took with you
that you used later on?
What were the
things that you were
able to keep with you that
when you were doing your search
helped you find your home?
SAROO BRIERLEY: Well, the
bond between mother and son--
and my siblings,
especially my sister--
that was fused pretty well.
I wasn't a child that was
taken and then let go of.
I was a lost child.
Not that it was any
fault of my own.
I suppose it would have
been a different situation
if I had been handed
over and said,
you're not wanted anymore.
It would have been a
totally different story.
But the yearning of wanting to
find my mother and especially
my sister, as well,
because I was her carer.
There was a major drive, as
in when it comes to family,
no one would ever
let go of family.
And I didn't want to be
disrespectful to my adoptive
family, but in my latter age--
I'm coming up to 30.
I'm an adult. I didn't tell
them about my searching
until later on I achieved
what I wanted to achieve.
And then would have told--
I did, actually.
I told them.
It's like I found hometown.
Is it OK, with your
permission, that I go back.
And they gave me
their permission,
said, yes, we would too,
would want the same thing
if we were in your position.
So it was all to do with family,
really, and not to give up,
as well as to diffuse those
weights on my shoulders that
had been there for
such a long time, which
was driven from
wanting to find out
that my mother's OK she's still
alive, and my sister as well.
She was so tiny, so little--
to wash her fingers
and her feet,
because they were so muddy,
and she was eating charcoal,
because there was no food.
I couldn't provide anything.
Just thinking about it would
just put tears to your eyes.
CASEY WHITELAW: So when you did
find your hometown on Google
Earth, how recognizable was it?
Because the imagery,
presumably, was
a lot different from
when you had left,
and your memories of it
from when you had left.
How did you really know that
you had found the right place?
SAROO BRIERLEY: I'm a great
person with convincing myself
with three things.
So when I saw it for the first
time, in the subconscious,
I know it's the place.
But I also wanted to see it
from a video, which was YouTube.
And so I just typed the name.
And then, all of
the sudden, there
was people going
through Khandwa,
my hometown, camcording--
high-definition, too.
And I was like, wow.
You can't be any more convinced.
And additionally to that,
I went onto Facebook
and typed in Khandwa.
And there was "Khandwa is
my Hometown" Facebook page.
And I wrote to the administrator
asking all these questions.
And he's coming back
with positive answers.
So there was Google Earth.
There was Facebook.
There was YouTube.
And that consolidated really
everything, as in even
though I was feeling quite, no,
this not right, still, but hey.
CASEY WHITELAW: I really
love hearing that it's--
in the movie, it's all very
much about you matching up
the imagery and so on.
But the other
sources that you're
talking about-- things like
YouTube, and Facebook-- just
point to the way that the
internet has really transformed
information these days.
We have this expectation that
we can go on and find anything,
as you said, about whether
it's a YouTube video
to help you learn guitar
or somebody walking down
the streets of your hometown
on the other side of the world,
it's all out there.
SAROO BRIERLEY: Yeah, well
I certainly embraced it.
There wasn't any
other way, really.
And imagine what the
Earth could be like
if everyone else
thought like that too,
of just using the internet in
whatever they wanted to find.
CASEY WHITELAW: And to
understand something
which is real different
from your own situation
too, to see something that's
not just your hometown-- not
your way you live yourself,
but something elsewhere
in the world.
Can you describe how it
felt when you got there
and when you really knew
that you were there,
standing in your home?
I can't fathom what
that would feel like.
I'd love to hear from you.
SAROO BRIERLEY: It's
such a pivotal moment.
I got to my hometown.
I threw my bag in the
corner of the hotel.
And I came to a
spot where I always
went to, either going to the
city or going back to home.
So it was a sort
of a central spot
for everyone, really, going
to the city and suburbia.
CASEY WHITELAW: And
this was in your memory
from when you were five?
SAROO BRIERLEY: Yeah.
CASEY WHITELAW: You could--
SAROO BRIERLEY: I pinpoint it.
It's the landmark that
I would go all the time.
And so as soon as I got
to this landmark, which
is the bridge with a underpass,
my legs had muscle memory.
And they just guided me.
I'm looking around,
thinking, you know,
this place looks
really different.
But these legs knew everything.
Amazing.
And they were just taking
me to the door of my house,
where I was born.
And I'm trying to fight.
I'm in a sort of a
state of indifference,
as in, why does
everything look so small--
and decayed, as well.
And it's been 25 years.
And things just
don't last forever.
And houses have fallen
apart, crumbled.
And new houses on top of the
old houses have been built upon.
And things look small.
It's because when you
were so short, or small,
everything looks so big.
But now you're so tall,
everything just looks so small.
And so you were finding that.
And it's like extrapolating and
trying to make sense of things.
But when I got to the front
door, and it looked a bit--
there's no one there.
And the worst got into you
and thought, they're dead,
or they moved somewhere else,
or they're not alive anymore.
And then a few people came
along and asked questions
about who are you, and
where are you from,
and what you're doing, and
what you're looking for.
And then that process of
telling them who I am,
and where I'm from, and who
are my family members began.
CASEY WHITELAW: Amazing.
SAROO BRIERLEY: So
that point, where
I was standing in front
of the door of my house,
is the sign points
where I was before
leaving to catch that train
25 years ago, to Burhanpur,
before I went onto that
frightful noise to Kolkata.
So there's a lot of recurrences.
But this happened then.
In 25 years, this happened
again at the same spot.
So themes always
come in that I'm
starting to realize from
an outsider looking in.
Amazing.
CASEY WHITELAW: I'd like
to switch now and ask
you some questions from
Google here and also
across Asia and the Pacific.
So here's one.
How has the technology
changed from when
you were on your search?
And do you think it would
be any easier for you today?
[LAUGHS]
SAROO BRIERLEY: Yes.
The high definition, I guess.
CASEY WHITELAW: Well plus the--
SAROO BRIERLEY: In
regards to Google Earth?
CASEY WHITELAW: The movie's out.
You could just watch the
movie and you'd know.
SAROO BRIERLEY: Well, that's
the other thing, yeah.
I didn't think about that.
But in regards
Google Earth, right?
CASEY WHITELAW: Or
technology overall.
SAROO BRIERLEY: Yeah, there's
just so much out there, really.
Where do you start?
But I think it's
up to the person,
really, that wants to know.
It's up to them to
press that button
and want to search
for things and so on.
It's at the touch of
our fingers, everything
that we want.
But it's really
up to you, really,
if you want to venture into that
journey of expanding your mind.
CASEY WHITELAW: Yeah.
People in this
office are working
on apps for what's described
as the next billion users.
So this is people in
developing nations,
such as India, who are starting
to access the internet,
mostly on mobile phones.
What services or
features do you think
would be useful if you
were a young person living
in India today?
SAROO BRIERLEY: Woo.
Gee, I love these
brainbusting questions.
As a young person, there is such
a different degree from poverty
to people in the
sectors of society.
and their availability
to access even a phone,
I guess, for starters, before
even going to applications.
But cost is everything,
isn't it, these days?
And the availability of
having that something that
is cost effective and
attainable for a kid, I guess--
it is a big question.
So if was in the situation,
as my nieces and nephews are,
I guess I'm not too sure.
Just it would be a cost factor.
Because not everyone
can afford it.
CASEY WHITELAW: Have
you spent much time
back there since you've
found your original family?
SAROO BRIERLEY: 15 times I've
been back within the four
years, which has been great.
Because the Big 10
event in Delhi--
and I went back to
do a talk there,
which allowed me to
go and see my family.
And then also with the book,
going back and retracing
everything with my ghost
writer, which allowed me
again to see my family,
and then the movie
as well, as well literary
fests and other faiths.
So it's been really good
to have all these things.
And on the side, I've always
gone and seen my family.
But additionally
to that too, I've
seen the orphanage
as well quite a lot.
There has to be harmony.
And I've being quite grateful
for what's happened to me.
But there are
children out there.
Their story's a
little bit different.
And it's what's
happened to them, too.
So helping out the orphanage
is a major, major thing
that I want to do and
have been doing, as well,
as well as seeing
my family, too.
CASEY WHITELAW: I'm going
to open up to the floor
here in Sydney, as well.
I'm sorry for the
people in other offices
that I can't open up to you.
There's a couple of microphones.
And I see a first
question up here
and then a second one
over at this side.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thanks for coming, first of all.
Amazing story.
I just wanted to ask,
have you had a chance
to try Google Earth and
the recently released
virtual reality?
It actually reminds
me of what you were
saying about astral projection.
It's quite a
powerful experience,
even for someone who doesn't
have the story that you have.
If you haven't tried it,
we'd be happy to show you.
SAROO BRIERLEY: Is
that the liquid--
CASEY WHITELAW: This is the VR.
SAROO BRIERLEY: Oh, the VR?
Oh, no, no, I haven't.
No, I haven't.
But yeah, sure,
I'd love to try it,
as long as it's not
scary as what I did.
CASEY WHITELAW: We're
sending you home
with a Daydream View today.
So we should be getting hooked
up on Google Earth on VR soon.
SAROO BRIERLEY: That'd be fun.
Love to, yeah.
I haven't tried it
yet, but I will.
CASEY WHITELAW: There was
a question just over here
as well.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Saroo.
Thanks so much for coming in.
It was awesome to listen to you.
I hear about a lot of
people who come into,
or who are met with bad
circumstances or big setbacks,
and they almost become
fearless afterward,
because they know
that they probably
won't hit that low again.
And you talk about
your ambition to leave
a legacy in the same line
as Tesla and these guys.
I'm wondering if
your experience has
made you somewhat fearless
against the kind of threat
or the setbacks that you
could face in that pursuit.
You know what I mean?
SAROO BRIERLEY: Yeah, yeah.
I guess being in Kolkata,
you had to be fearless.
And now being an adult, I guess
that's being in a lucky country
you become a little--
more fear, I guess, because
you're not in the same world,
in the same realm.
There's India, which
you fight to survive.
Then it's Australia.
It's a Westernized
world, as opposed to--
in a different world.
And I guess I've
become a bit soft.
But Saroo, as a child, as
a five-year-old, contending
what he did, reminds me of
if Saroo saw you now kind
of thing, getting scared
in front of a spider,
he'd be shame on you.
You know what I mean?
[LAUGHTER]
So he always reminds me.
He's that little guidance to
give me strength all the time.
And you sometimes forget.
But yeah, I'm very lucky to
have him, even though it's me.
[LAUGHS] He reminds
me of myself.
He's like, look
what you've done,
and look what you've
conquered, and what
you've been through, and so on.
So I always get reminded by him.
I hope that answered
your question.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Saroo.
Thank you so much for coming in.
I've really enjoyed
listening to you.
I'd love to hear more about
what your family are doing now--
your mum and your sister
and what they're up to.
SAROO BRIERLEY: Hey,
look, one of the things
is I bought my mum a house.
And--
[APPLAUSE]
Before, as children we couldn't
afford anything really.
We lived on renting and having
milk, pretty much something
sustainable, as opposed
to other things,
which we couldn't afford.
But a built her a house--
bought her a house,
which is the same house
that she's been living
in for the last 25 years.
And she didn't want to
move to another house.
She wanted to stay there.
Her friends are close by.
I helped my sister out.
I helped my brother out.
And they've got houses as
well, and helping my niece
and nephews as well for
schooling and so on.
So they're doing OK.
So I'm happy to do that.
Why wouldn't anyone else
do the same thing anyway?
AUDIENCE: So my question
was actually very similar,
about your family.
And obviously this is
a very incredible story
and a story that the world has
attached itself to and wants
to hear and has gathered
some international attention.
And your family is
very excited now
that you found them
and you're reconnected.
How do they feel about
the international exposure
of this story?
Is it something that
is difficult for them?
Or do they really
want to share it?
I imagine that that's
a very personal thing.
SAROO BRIERLEY: My
biological family?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, your
biological family.
SAROO BRIERLEY: Yeah, look,
I don't think they really
understood the extent of
what this story is globally,
and the book and the movie.
I think that they're just
very conservative people.
And I don't think it hit them
until now of what it really is
and how amazing it is to people.
It's a unique, profound story.
And I guess they're
a bit like me,
too-- you know,
seeing is believing.
I heard a lot of things.
But when I saw it, it
made my feelings change.
And so now it's really hit them.
And they're quite
like, wow, really?
This is my son.
This is us.
It's a story about
what has happened.
But they're humble and
grateful about everything.
And I think the end of the
day, for them, it's really
that I'm back in their lives.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I wonder how are your
sleeping patterns now?
SAROO BRIERLEY: Oh,
where do I start?
I just got in from
Bahrain last night.
Not building sandcastles, but--
AUDIENCE: Did the dreams stop
once you found your hometown?
SAROO BRIERLEY: Yeah, it did.
The weights on my
shoulders diffused.
And those dreams of the astral
projection-- all that stopped.
I don't have them anymore.
I haven't had them
for four years.
So that gives me a
better sleep, I guess.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm not so moody in the
morning, not wanting
to do my chores in the house--
back then, you know.
But you know what,
actually just to expand
on that, having those astral
projection isn't always
a good thing for people,
having flashes come back
at you during the night
and during the day.
Having a photographic
memory of things
isn't always great, of
being retold something
that you don't want to see
anymore or think about anymore.
But I'm very fortunate and lucky
that those astral projections
and dreams were there
for a reason, a guidance
from my brother that
was pushing and pulling
the energy of the
universe, being there too,
the planets or celestial
beings aligning in a way
to find my way back home.
AUDIENCE: I have two quick
hypothetical questions.
The first is, how
long would you have
kept on looking had you not
found them after five years?
And the second is, if you could
guide your five-year-old self
to get on the right train,
would you have done it,
or would you just keep
going on the wrong train?
SAROO BRIERLEY: I would have
searched until the day I
would have died.
It's not something I
would have given up.
When I come across
something, I don't give up.
I believe that everything
is possible in this world.
Life is just a jigsaw.
What we want to do in
finding things, whatever
it may be, as
crazy as it sounds,
there's a way of getting there.
It just takes time to get there.
So for me, I would
have kept on going.
But in regards to the
train, sometimes catching
the wrong train can get
you to the right station.
And that's how, I
guess, it was for me.
Even though I went through so
much trials and tribulations,
I came out at the end, from my
adoptive mother's perspective,
traumatized, but I
disassociated myself.
Even though I always had the
memories, but I didn't let
them overtake me.
So I guess it was
just my destiny
to go through what I did.
And it just happened that way--
some of it not so
fruitful and nice.
But it just happened that way.
And let's not cry
over spilt milk.
AUDIENCE: Saroo,
one of the things
that touched me in the film
was when you set off the train
and spoke a different
language to the people who
surrounded you.
I'm just curious as to
do you recall any of--
I think it was Hindi in the
film is the way it's presented.
Do you still speak any Hindi?
Do you remember any?
Have you learnt any since being
reconnected with your family?
SAROO BRIERLEY: Look, I only
knew about six to seven words
of Hindi.
That's it.
I couldn't even string
a sentence together.
And hence, I
couldn't articulate.
Coming to Kolkata was--
you speak Bengali there.
So I didn't speak Bengali.
And I only spoke a few words
of Hindi and that's it.
My best friend was my sister.
She couldn't even say anything.
And so that was against me.
And the first thing that
you learn as a child
is what's your mum's
name, your last name,
your father's
name, phone number,
and the street that you live in.
But I didn't have that.
My knowledge was very minimal.
And I had to use
my visual memories,
which were heightened, as
opposed to my auditorial.
And that's why I have
these memories of my past,
and my hometown, and the
architecture of the place,
and so on.
So yeah, Calcutta
was very difficult.
No one would understand
what I was saying, really.
But when I asked for
Burhanpur, no one would know.
It's like, where?
AUDIENCE: What's next?
You spent five years-- drive,
determination, full commitment
to a cause.
What's next in the
plan after the book?
SAROO BRIERLEY: Well,
it's a bit crazy.
But I want to get into
physics, so space propulsion.
Yeah.
I'm not going to shoot myself
what I'm going to do with it.
That's a bit ahead of my time.
But that's next for me.
And I'm in the process of
writing the prequel to "Lion,"
which is talking about
how from adoptive mother
to my biological mother to
Saroj Sood, the lady that
helped at the orphanage
to get me to Australia--
how they're all related, from
states apart to oceans apart,
and how their
dreams and what they
want to do in life in
regards to helping children
has come about.
From Saroj Sood, who's the
owner of the orphanage in India,
ISSA, how she three went through
her trials and tribulations,
with Mother Teresa helping
out and so on, and then
wanting to go out by herself,
and her family situation
as well, from being
a lawyer to wanting
to help children in India
that are in so much need.
So I think putting the
prequel out and the story--
a book first and then
hopefully a movie next--
would really make people
understand even more in depth
what "Lion" is about as well,
because it goes even deeper.
So there's that end and
my crazy thing as well.
CASEY WHITELAW: I think that's
a really great place for us
to wrap up.
So Saroo, thank you so much
for your time and coming in.
SAROO BRIERLEY: Thank you.
CASEY WHITELAW: Yeah,
everyone, thank Saroo.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAROO BRIERLEY: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]